the daughter of former of a former
Russian double agent poisoned in England
says she's growing stronger every day
British police released a statement
yesterday from Sergei Street Paul's
daughter Yulia it's her first public
comments since she and her father were
sickened by a nerve agent Russia denies
any involvement in the attack last month
Charlie d'Agata recently traveled to
Moscow he shows us the Kremlin's efforts
to discredit allegations that it was
responsible Russian state television
appeared to have pulled off a coup the
first phone call allegedly between Yulia
scruple and her cousin victorious
everything is fine and fixable she's
heard saying and as for her father
Sergei x' health nobody has any problems
that can't be put right even Russian TV
said the audio couldn't be verified it's
just the latest episode in a month-long
campaign of alternate reality by Russian
state media ever since Britain accused
the Kremlin of directing an attack on
the Russian spy and his daughter using
the Russian made nova chalk nerve agent
a popular TV host and blaming Russia
it's a bit like saying if someone's hit
in the head with an iPad America is to
blame because the iPad is the u.s.
inventions which is absurd
yes but absurdity is part of this of
this show what a Cal Fishman is the
former editor of The Moscow Times
something is managing managing every
message it sends through federal
television this is how basically Russian
nation gets its political agenda and it
is a message that appears to be getting
through do you believe the British you
don't of course not I can say that I'm a
veteran of my country I think it's just
like anti Russian strategy because the
Russian strategy yes they're not alone
well not everybody we recently spoke to
in Moscow
fully buys their own country's story
nobody believes Britain's version of
events for CBS this morning Charlie
d'Agata London